I'm hoping to convince you that EIFRE, it has a new function that should be explored further.
These are my disclosures.
So my laboratory has been highly interested in leukemia stem cells.
As we heard now several times, it's its role during MRD and the desire to eliminate this population that we know can lead to disease relapse.
So through this journey, we have found many different approaches that have led us to potentially selective targeting of leukemia stem cells without harming hematopoietic stem cells.
But yet, still, we have the same problem that this population is difficult to eradicate.
One of the pathways that we're interested in is the interaction of the leukemia stem cell with the...
microenvironment.
And this is where we explored a new function for EIFRE in this context.
It was well known that EIFRE has a role in migration in solid tumors.
And it was thought that this role had to do with just the production of proteins that were involved in metastasis.
So EIFRE, the role that we all know and we're familiar with is the initiation of protein...
the initiation of...
of translation and protein synthesis.
We also know that sometimes has preferred mRNA targets.
And these targets have to do with cell growth, survival, and angiogenesis.
We also know that EIFRE is involved in mRNA transport from the nucleus to the cytoplasm.
It's also known to regulate splicing.
It's well known to be overexpressed in several cancers, including breast, prostate, lymphoma, leukemia.
And also multiple myeloma.
It has been reported several years ago, I was involved in this work as a post...
as a graduate student, so it's a long time ago, that in a subset of AML samples, EIFRE can be found localized in the nucleus.
And this is a subset of M4s and M5s AMLs.
So because of that, it was always an interest of targeting EIFRE through time.
And...
And in a collaboration with...
Cathy Borden, that now is at Northwestern University, we started exploring if EIFRE could have a role
in the interaction of the leukemia stem cells with the microenvironment.
To this end, we used several tools.
We used genetic manipulation of EIFRE, in which we down-regulated EIFRE using CRISPR-Cas technology
or overexpressed EIFRE using vectors.
Also, we used a pharmacological inhibition.
This with ribavirin as a way to inhibit EIFRE.
The assays we used, we measured adhesion, invasion, colonization using a novel 3D system
that we have shown can stimulate the growth of leukemia stem cells inside this spheroid.
And also, we used AML xenografts.
What we found, as you can see here in blue, when you overexpress EIFRE,
you increase adhesion, invasion, and colonization of these...
these AML cells.
If you down-regulate EIFRE, we decrease adhesion, invasion, and colonization,
suggesting, again, that EIFRE, if you manipulate EIFRE, you can control these processes.
Importantly, if we use these cells in xenografts, we see that we can decrease the engraftment
of AML cells that down-regulate EIFRE.
And importantly, these animals can have an increased overall survival, as you can see in the picture.
Also, if we look early on at the bone marrow of these mice, if you can see in the floor plots,
it's very difficult to identify these leukemia cells in the bone marrow of these animals.
So somehow, these cells fail to find their home.
We also evaluated this using revivirin as a pharmacological inhibition of EIFRE,
and we found that when we treat the AML cells with revivirin, we decrease the invasion of these cells.
And also, we found that when we treat the AML cells with revivirin, we decrease the invasion of these cells.
And also, if we look early on at the bone marrow of these mice, if you can see in the floor plots, it's very difficult to identify these leukemia cells in the bone marrow of these animals.
And also, in xenograft models, this is patient-derived xenografts, in this case showing AML55, you can see that we also improve overall survival of these mice.
So when we look at the machinery that is involved in the motility processes, specifically esrin, which plays a critical role in the cytoskeleton,
we found that when we immunoprecipitate EIFRE, we can bring the EIFRE to the bone marrow of these animals.
bring down esrin and the translation machinery. And also when we pull down esrin, we bring down
the translation machinery and EIF-4E, as shown in this slide. We evaluated an assay. We had to
develop an assay to identify active translation using imaging, as shown here, using ribolase,
which is a biotinylated form of puromycin. So using this assay, you can see here that we can
co-localize the translation machinery, EIF-4E, esrin, CD44, all to the membrane of the cell,
right where the cell dopos are forming as the cell is trying to move.
And here is the measurement. When we use siRNA to esrin or EIF-4E, you can see we can decrease
that localization of the translation machinery to the membrane of the cell. And also when
we downregulate either esrin or EIF-4E, suggesting that there is a very novel role of EIF-4E bringing
the whole translation machinery to the membrane to synthesize these mRNAs and initiate protein
translation on site to allow the movement of these cells. EIF-4E targeting has been tested
in several clinical trials, shown here, showing promise for EIF-4E targeting.
The reason that has not been continued was because EIF-4E ribavirin, in this case,
when combined with citarabine, citarabine can block the absorption of ribavirin.
But there is still interest with combining ribavirin with other potential drugs.
So just to summarize, I hope I convinced you that there is still hope for targeting EIF-4E
or any of other partners interacting with EIF-4E at the membrane, because this could,
in fact, avoid the interaction of leukemia stem cells with the microenvironment and allow for
better targeting of these cells. And just thank you for your attention. And this is my group.
We still celebrate Day of the Dead as a good Mexican. Thank you very much.